hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to infiltrate the airship
the next game in the line of games made
by the same guys that made the other
games like stealing the diamond and
escaping the pretty wagon oh this is the
worst intro ever anyway it's the next
game in the series but in my quest to
play them completely out of order I'm
gonna play this one next and then if I
have time at the end of it I'm gonna
play breaking the bank - because I heard
that one's really sure either way I'm
just gonna play it I'm gonna get through
this I'm we're all gonna be okay we're
all gonna get through this together
what are you alright there sir finally
decided weaker me you've been quite
elusive but your skills make you put the
catch you'll be perfectly jab we've been
having some issues with a group of
thieves known as the top ad clan okay
guilty
you just can't pin them to any grunts
you'll be going into the airship to
bring down I don't need to remind you
that we've got you on several charges
tempting robbery breaking yourself out
of prison even stealing tunisian diamond
job we've got quite a lot of cancer so
great in mood rebel charges against you
whatever surely he would be bringing you
close to the airship uh-huh is it to you
uh-huh I know way to bring him down
mmm-hmm okay but I thought I was already
a free man because according to me in
all the alternate universes that I did I
oh oh so many choices cannonball
I mean looking at the numbers Hugh what
do you think oh yes let me have a look
hahaha wait what oh I survived it holy
crap I didn't think I would actually
make that one yeah bring it on table
Patti laser yeah how is my little
orbital goal well okay we are I okay
back to science here a laser doesn't
have any mass well light does have mass
but it's an insignificant amount of mass
lasers don't cause thrust they don't let
ion drive would cost for us but lasers
wouldn't it's not okay okay how about
the thruster I would understand if the
thrusters gonna throw
me back okay okay okay I'm gonna stop
questioning the physics of these kids
Wow oh you you smashed through the front
window you can't smash into a little bit
of a wall ah
all right the chair yeah
oh that's a comfy chair Oh dancer ball
it's a sonic ball I just played Sally
how do you see so I'm totally into the
whole sonic whatever you got going on
that one there
oh I got a reflex we got to react ha oh
I guess I didn't need to react ha ha ha
ha ha I didn't know those doing don't
judge me you can judge me this game
cannot BAM I'm out of here baby you
thought you'd get me I'm going huh yes
yes oh god do I need to react please yes
beans ha ha I had that I had that I
gotta go back because I got to try out
this other one because people got upset
because they didn't get all of the fails
and I want to give you all bow I am Bear
one the world and what okay then that
didn't make any sense how did I have
those thrusters in me and O'Kane
everybody you know whatever whatever I'm
just gonna deal with this I'm gonna eat
my can of beans and you are gonna do it
I would never eat the beans
yeah those helped ha ha all right never
know when it's gonna take like the real
physics router the wrong physics route
I'm still Larry's butts down though
metalbend rocket jump yeah that'll work
out this one won't work
of course okay that oh that one works
God I'm trying to pick the failures here
all right fine wait you got your finger
I'm gonna Dirk here ha ha what
Oh God really whoa no way
suplex that train man deep dead yet what
Wow huh this is a bunch of baloney
techno trousers that's it that's from
Wallace and Gromit Wallace and Gromit
did that I remember that I remember the
trouser from Wallace and Gromit they
were great anyone watch Wallace and
Gromit anymore all right I got to go
back this is gonna get convoluted here
because there's a lot of opportunities I
need to try and I got lucky cuz I picked
the right ones off the bat which is not
usually how I go about things I try to
fail first metal fist take my fist bruh
oh I think it would have been cooler if
you turned into a rhino
now tell me huh well now I'll be right
back
anyway like I was saying how would I
have turned into a rhino uh uh what some
are not mentally prepared enough for
alternate-dimension okay whatever you
say bro
activate the doors yeah hey we've all
seen this before multiple times now for
my series of failures go go my party
friend go I don't know what it is about
these games they're just delightful just
adorably delightful metalbend Ben man
metal what Oh like avatar Bend oh you're
a bender Harry I don't think you know
what you're talking about Gandalf hmm or
are you Australian boosted I will get
you on Oh
earthbound well we went from final
fantasy the earthbound that's awesome
it's so awesome
flash B flash B would just block oh man
something got my god earthbound it's so
cool oh oh show me memories oh no oh my
god earthbound is one of my favorite
games of all times I mean today multi
bottle rocket hell yeah
yes the bottle rockets always win god I
loved earthbound so much I played it
when I was a kid and it blew my mind
even before I knew my mind could be
blown Oh what do you got for me now
glider jab blue beefed up I want to know
what beefed-up is oh how did that happen
that's not right jet boots I feel like
these whoa well alright then I guess the
sensible option would be the best one I
was just assuming that jet boots would
be made to standard what alright then
hey it was very good very graceful I
forget what I'm what am I trying to do
about this I'm trying to like capture
something to do with the tophat clan
feeds my right-hand man
I surrender the airship to you wait how
do I do that
do I have a choice again oh I do oh man
it's so many choice
tank love it how it is
that didn't do it like I thought it do
what they're alive Wow
this document is to certify that Henry
stickmin has been pardoned of all crimes
prior to 2013
okey doke even good for Henry achieved
the rank of relentless bounty hunter
awesome but I didn't want to pick the
winning one I wanted to pick the funny
FAIL and i parachute here we go mmm-hmm
is this is this parachute actually a
parachute and better okay oh well
butterfingers yeah you think I would
have packed - all right missile I like
the idea of missile on second thought
that might not have been such a good
idea well a lot of things weren't such a
good idea
oh and we're dead horribly dead big fall
I'm sure Henry had a plan what is it
rapidly promoted executive I like that
achievement I mean who needs to be
pardoned of all crimes when you could
just be the crime this lovely anyway I
got a start rag from beginning again
there's so many options sticky hand
wow that's okay is that worked
zero-point energy of course yes yes what
the hell man goddamn if you have that
you need to do it right you [ __ ] ball
and chain
hey did you hear something over there
why are you doing these things you idiot
oh you're alive good
yay that was quick lightning quick luck
I didn't know that's what I was going
for oh no no no no whoever is me I did
it I did it
your piece guess check check Charles
thought I'd uh give you a heads up it's
a guy down there a bad guy so uh yeah
good luck thanks Charles
I'm gonna knock oh come on look that's
business than me see for how about that
knock first blam oh you know when they
blow stuff up they say take cover that's
why you're very funny with all of your
right and wrong physics ha ha that's
horrible
I'll give these a stick figure so go
away pretty quickly wait what exactly
are you sucking up there Bremen a ting
something we can use to prove that
they're criminals mm-hmm Oh point
evaporation
all right gentlemen we've been tasked
with developing new weapons for the clan
any ideas it's gonna think it yeah yeah
ah transdimensional Iser sounds cool
visit alternate dimensions with the
flick of a switch it's super easy to use
and gives awesome results I seem to
recall traveling through a dimension
earlier in this guy ah very clever with
your dimensional joke there glue what am
I get what why oh this is a terrible
idea
you do realize how much a solid-gold
cannon would weigh doubt yeah dude we
totally got enough power what do you
think man well I'm still kind of new
here so I'm not really sure what to say
oh it works
I totally didn't expect that to work at
all record sign where it says records
I'd probably be a good place to look
right okay help you get across that gap
Oh
Robo helper right here comes wait you're
gonna oh wait if you're gonna send it to
me right then and there why didn't you
before well that was easy
I'm not intentionally picking the right
choices again I'm trying to fail now I
have to go back into two different
varieties bone meltem melt his bones Oh
God
oh that's a horrible I pick the right
choice again you got so many wrong
choices now good god there's so many oh
yeah I'm losing it
I'm losing my mind go well that got is
what what okay all right then oh oh yes
I have to go back now I I don't want to
continue any farther until I go back I
just want to see this one again it's cuz
it didn't expect it Oh God I I'm gonna
get back to where I was
okay here's the first thing I miss yeah
look at him there hey yeah what what do
you think you're doing
ah right what are you doing here mate
your wife's just gone into labor
thank they escape pod behind you he'll
take you right to the hospital
good don't worry I'll tell the chief is
okay
alright now back to where I was going
okay let's see what you got with the
platform okay let me just
put this thing in here for you Oh
all these thoroughly horrifying tragic
ways to die like gravity should be able
to get you to float across great idea
great idea so bad
killing everybody
we worry no oh this game is killing me I
love it so much just get through there
you stupid Robo tails god I bet enough
of Sonic for one day okay let's see what
else we got here I forgot there's so
many that I missed mine control yes you
are under my suggestion what what what
did he do what the hell happened
okay Gatling guy don't don't shoot me
please
oh wow hahaha everyone's dead everyone
you're horrible hacked into their
security system should be able to open
the door from here okay come on and slam
welcome to the gym is that really
appropriate in this situation here mmm
just melt his bones and be done Oh God
sour ball okay spookier I'm gonna spook
you good hello mr. spider Oh beautiful I
love it
hello is game say wait it looks like you
can get around if you go through that
air duct
alright I've hacked into their power
grid what do you want me to do whoa hey
now make an animal noise
it okay I don't understand what that
means
hey Sun is gonna do something if it
repeated alright I don't need your help
I just thought you needed some help is
all hahahahaha heart instantly explode
in chess um shut off the power that's
Carl gonna shot the whole ship isn't it
yep I knew it how did I know it I'm so
smart
yay ok let's just do the roll huh hey
come on got it
schedules are keep let's go let's go
there's like more there's like twice as
many animations in this one and there
ever has been either that or I'm hunting
them down a little better oh that's it
it's a funny joke II overexposed all
those photos no you don't Wow ok force
gun hey there's a button on your
earpiece should press it did I really
just pick the right choice again Oh what
what these could be a problem yeah it
could be a problem but I think I did
what I'm alive government supported
private investigator okay then I have to
retry that cuz merrily I'm really good
at picking the water hey what are you
doing there choppa what okay why is that
coming them alright banana bomb
worms joke worms revolution Joker pretty
much any of the worms jokes I like it
left counter-strike why would you walk
into that your son's an idiot god you're
so stupid all right so that's all of
those for now back to the start because
there's a whole nother avenue to go good
golly BAM
take that so many bomb bomb Iran that
was it Oh
am i dead wow I'm dead yeah I didn't
have to swell it up all that much oh
that was the right one I gotta go back
again I'm too good at picking computer
no no
oh no man come on uh I'll lead your life
away oh well all right then this guy's a
true gamer at heart elevator I meant to
go back to the other one to that one
okay I guess I'm off to the hospital
again goodbye everybody
I need step back one joy buzzer joy
concert what kind of joy buzzer we talk
no not again why why is that tied to
everything expanding foam how is this
not gonna work it looks like it looks
like the Helicarrier grew a little bit
of a sac underneath him very good
I just noticed this there's a key on the
desk here am I supposed to pick that up
look okay II get what does that mean
I'll go in the vents now thank you
oh yeah sucked in the vents there that
looks important
that looks bigger than the diamonite
wait ah so I'm on the other side now
teleporter that works so well
okay worked a little too well I've gone
to the plane of infinity well I'd better
kill kay bye thanks you're so helpful
magic pencil like from spans Bab it
might end horribly Oh ended her bleed
all right um leap sure okay
what and my apologies everyone had to
deploy some evasive maneuvers flock of
ducks flew by I can't believe that
worked
oh hey guy hello again how's it going
think you could let me out of here I
have the key I get that was slightly
erotic the way you did that but I don't
care I'm gonna keep going
wizard magic yes roll the one okay I'm
gonna get back real quick stretch him
what oh that's horrible
Oh goddamn it I [ __ ] everything up
area I hope that's back to where it was
before if it's not then I'm screwed
okay power glove the best oh it doesn't
actually do anything does it
okay thanks yeah you're great hack that
would be the logical choice but okay
well that didn't do it what are you
doing oh oh okay let's breathe I thought
Wade wrote this for a second paper eyes
it
oh no he became a stick figure what that
actually works
okay hi there goes that guard I guess it
was a point to me unlocking him maybe
claw pack gravity gun that one no uh
shrinking and grow claw back shrinking
grow well I guess that worked then no
let's go No
looks like he set off some sort of alarm
vault what he's gone rogue all right
dude Plan B : reinforcements move it
Wow two choppers a what the hell oh
that's not good is it
wait if I was right there and I'm
assuming that I'm in the middle of the
fan why are they shooting pistols at
each other shell power armor propane
tank oh my god there's so many options
Chao what why
oh no no you presented it as an option
all right I step back real quick Bob at
what why why why oh it's not my Burt oh
my god oh it's like the Banjo and
Kazooie okay we're back now propane tank
go oh wow what ha just exploded
Hank Hill quote ah get a little tired
are we power armor from fallout still
dead oh you're alive
what
tell me that whoa uh and it just so
happen to grow right then and there
Wow
no Wilson we've gotta get out of here I
can't set up front doorstep we're not
built to deal with this man go evacuate
everyone I can take care of this oh do I
have to choose really I have to choose
this ah okay deep I don't know what
these are
dark energy blaster what Oh No oh fail
what we made I didn't do that
all right guys step back one more time
because got try out what the umbrella
does it kill me okay I thought it would
all right there we go I'm dead now be
right back
oh let's try this again whatever the
hell this is Elka laser Oh laser cut
that's good might be bad what why do you
explain that one what take her from nice
patrick Star references good whatever
while disc is scratched out gay gaben
gayben Yap gave it no no
ah
oh no no prototype all right well yeah
for me Wow
okay those don't look nearly as cool as
you think they do I was like in fact
very stupid oh it's a sword arm okay
well they're dead hey let's go to Ruby
we rant about it we've got to retreat
rust atomic plan will be history
hello what really really really in the
middle of the war zone in the middle of
a battlefield right by a giant Ruby that
couldn't be missed
you'd take a leak all right what what is
Ken let him go what yeah I did it pure
blooded thief and that's all I am I
think I got every single one of them did
I miss any I don't think I did I did it
I did it all right
hey this went on a long time but that
was so much fun I can't believe how much
work went into that I mean I know the
amp animations are simplistic animations
but still that was really cool
try for another fifty five total fails
54 unique fails I guess I did it I think
but either way if I missed one maybe you
can find it maybe deep down dug in there
there's a few Easter eggs that you might
enjoy so check them out
play the game for yourself as always in
the description below thank you again
everybody so much for watching check out
the other games in the series that I
played I don't have time to play break
into the bank but that'll just be a
short video at another time so thanks
again everybody and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
Wow
hahaha and I know run up and right back
to where I started it it's a light very
detailed scenario so so in this lake
house in upstate New York in the
Catskills Catskills Catskills